[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
ce carré d'as et même confié hier la
corniche a estimé marie idrac
elle n'a affirmé labouheyre
moi j'aime bien c'est entre les
franchisés il ya une personne qui a
dévissé n'a pu ni ce qu a dévissé dans
la voix des français où la voix des
dalles ou au pouce donc apparemment
latinistes cet inconscient au plus près
par victor matos et de 10 coquinou
récupère on va se faire trier dans la
voix et puis on verra ce qu'on fait sur
place
départ d'olivier py et après 0,4
oh
la poussée qui ont relais
le gars qui pendent au bout de cinq ans
je veux du sang partout
le cercle de sang
le tutoie gymnique au calme
opposé à tout
nous poser leurs et on va médicalisé ici
parce que les cas il vous était vaches
et c'était mon autre pluie
[Musique]
cinq essais sont multiples et ça
ouais bravo lima pour crampons honnart
si tu peux poser le mec sur le glacier
plus haut sur le névé
richard kingson
[Musique]
et les branchements
mais bon tu m'as tu vu
aspirateur un peu pourquoi pas du coach
ça marche café mois le scotch g tenir
comme ça
ok on s'aimait son respirateur sur
machine ouais ben branches où il va se
réveiller un accord at elle joué les
brunchs et un vague ouais ça va à peu
près là c'est tu vois c'est beaucoup
plus calme quand ils assurent ils sont
intubés comme ça beaucoup plus détendus
ils râlent quoi il souffre plus donc
trauma crânien glasgow 4 un tube et
ventilés je vais demander un hôpital de
chamonix on va te pas aller à sallanches
- bellion faut qu'on fasse un bilan
mondial et après faut que tu organises
un transfert secondaire sur genève aussi
rapide que possible
vous
bon goût
difficile à vivre ces situations
bon parce que enfin c'est pas difficile
on est pris dans l'action que on se
posera des questions après qu'on fait
bomber saint philippe qui était pierre
laurent qui était dans la face ça
retourne il est parti c'est déjà pas mal
non non c'était impossible se faire
trier je me suis douté mais moi je
pouvais pas me faire travailler sur lui
non plus directement parce que j'ai vu
les cailles en thuya l'élargissement les
noms mais là oui sûrement mais sur quoi
ils tiennent au dessus quand il est
arrivé un truc de cette gravité là je
pense que ça doit être vraiment la
libération de voir les secours arrivent
et je crois pour là je regrette pas mon
choix je pense que c'est une autre
cordée
j'étais passé quoi parce qu'ils n'ont
pas de radio et non pas de téléphone et
malgré tout mais maintenant ça sera
quand même si vous avez une radio de
téléphones bon c'est bon ils sont
autonomes
là il y aurait pas eu l'accord des à
côtés il restait pas nui et puis il
pouvait un peu les ailes plat il ya
personne hein y'a personne
tu es content quand tu as fait un truc
comme ça tu as servi à quelque chose
c'est pas c'est pas c'est du vrai ça
c'est pas du virtuel
la pression tombe
[Musique]
sont tous les toubibs quoi qui nous pose
souci surtout les jeunes casser la
gueule aux pilotes ce temps en temps ça
fait suer au lagon la poussée billy
talent et quand même y aller pas y aller
non mais je vais pas juger des toits à
la vue des crêpes avec dalkia maison
exactement pour ce recours que que je
fais ce métier c'est pas du ramassage
pas d'évacuation de confort c'est un mec
les blessés souffrent qui a besoin de
soins qui a besoin d'être évacués parce
qu'il peut pas descendre tout seul donc
voilà c'est donc à mon avis ou est
vraiment notre classement par rapport à
un smur où il ya toujours un médecin en
affirmant qu'ils ont peut-être la clé
tout seul par tuer les gendarmes
quittent est qu'ils sont très compétents
pour ça en fait t'as pas le temps de
penser
par contre dans un deuxième temps c'est
en fin de journée ou ce soir 38 ans chez
toi là tu penses des fois certains trucs
que tu as vu quoi ça m'arrive aussi dû
penser quand tu quand tu grimpes quand
tu fais des voix des fois tu peux pas
t'empêcher de dire matière j'ai ramassé
quelque chose ici quelqu'un ici j'ai
j'ai vu ça ici tu penses tu mets après
un de plus mais à quoi sert normalement
ouardiri jimmy la mort fait partie
intégrante de la pratique de la montagne
qui a perdu un ami tu as perdu tu as
perdu un frère ou un compagnon de cordée
ça arrive ça fait partie d'une autre
pratique que la montagne a pas d'autre
choix
en tout cas moi le m'apporte beaucoup
plus de joie que de tristesse donc c'est
pour ça que je continue à la pratiquer
mais tout en sachant que des fois c'est
on peut simplement avoir des petits
trucs éviter que ça se transforme en
tragédie quoi qu'une telle journée se
transformer le noir
[Musique]
le monde
paris
quoi cela choque pas au niveau des
mouvements
ouais mais cela tient à dire qu'on se
mettre à plusieurs pour le porter
jusqu'à la machine ça va ça va pas de
l'auberge des policiers c'est le
quotidien du pghm aussi c'est pas que
les grand secours dans la face nord des
droites
c'est aussi tous ces petits secours du
quotidien qui sont importants sur une
année en fait sur les plus de 1000
secours qui sont réalisés quasiment 30%
ces secours qui ont lésé en randonnée
pédestre et sur ces 30 pour 100 g avec
80% c'est des petites des petites
pathologies c'est des entorses et des
gens fatigués c'est des gens qui ont en
altitude pour l'alpinisme des mal aigu
des montagnes passé c'est ce registre de
la con appellent la bobologie
mais si on devait faire que du secours
hyper technique ont très usés gir des
gens il résistera pas gérer mentalement
et psychologiquement donc l'alternance
dans ce court avec une technicité
relativement faible et surtout un
engagement moral et affectif à lacets
faible sa sympathie du festivent secours
fait que c'est viable les journées sont
sera traitée pour les secouristes
si à chamonix l'organisation du secours
est particulière d'avoir elle est fondée
sur cette histoire qui date depuis de 40
ans d'expérience commune ce qui fait la
force à chamonix c'est la
complémentarité des équipes à la fois de
la part bien entendu des gendarmes
secouristes des et les équipages la sécu
des civils et la gendarmerie et aussi
des médecins donc c'est cette équipe qui
travaille dans une proximité avec une
très forte technicité montagne et une
culture montagne partagé par l'ensemble
des partenaires qui fait l'efficacité
surtout ici
[Musique]
cordiale pour crampons il ya trois gars
ont dévissé à l'apathie de weert et sont
tombés dans l'arrivée de ont déjà été
dégagés vous devriez les croisés en
comptant et l'autre et aux noix ou en
train de perm a démenti les armes il est
on va tirer la trace il est juste la
rime est sous le sommeil me disaient les
gars juste russe mais larry mai
ils seront pas là ok
ouais high tech ou vip l'on va la
regarder maintenant ça va il bouge ses
bons d'essence à bord
c'est essentiel et urgent
attendu non cordiale on vient du
téléphérique pour les peugeot cela pour
l'hôpital de savone e-reçu moi j'étais à
ce qu'on appelle la salle à manger quoi
on était alors qu'on attendait qu'ils
arrivent parce que bon c'est un truc que
le recomptage qui il est tombé à la cour
et pousser les avoirs pourrait céder
quoi on ira faire tout de suite hein
parce que c'est la poudreuse autre jour
et à promettre que moi je te promets
scordia quelqu'un qui a dévissé dans
l'accord de bangui sous la neige
mais après je sais pas très bien on
attend attendez attendez je fais que
c'est un rôle et une plaque à neige qui
est parti vous êtes parti pour mieux je
suis parti le premier ou et les autres
ont suivi
g
il me rassurait sur piolet way est parti
à mon avis tous les trois je les ai
retrouvés au bord de fleurance le
premier au fond évidemment retenu par la
cort inconscient et bien d'autrui
l'autre mais voilà il troisième qui
avait rien mais il a les dents cassées
mais ça va si vous avez un peu de vert
dans la gorge on l'a fait on a tout
enlevé que l'allemand était bleu donc la
sortie non non le montant un peu rouge
dégager son visage et là on est allé
comme elle je crois qu'il est resté on
se dit quand même car le plus d'un quart
d'heure tout peut-être même chose il ya
descendu la pente
debout à temps le premier l'a donc celui
qui a dévissé de premier tiers
il revient à l'état ses traits pôle tpe
d'errements il faut le poser voilà ses
pairs et besoin se faisait poser
tu as repris mais quid des cardiaques
temps je vais vous brancher des crucifix
comme ça c'est un gag
donc le plafond est bien dégagé il ya un
léger vent mais je pense qu'on peut
faire avec la machine qui veulent venir
récupérer la victime la wiimote envolés
les coûts privé tout de suite on
continue à descendre
allez bon j'étais toi c'est bien des
changements tandis que je t en tension
que j'ai encore à venir sa moto si toi
tu voulais me convaincre bush
il sera décollera les allées temps il a
tout du coup l'aller ils avaient le
temps
ce gars vient quand on touche la passion
vélo que maintenant les retards routard
contrôler quant à chaud au coeur et au
corps allez on passe
bravo qu'ils ont pourtant nombreuses à
l'est on arrive ce qu'on en dit long
là pour moi qui regarde
les craintes que les
les crampons ces 130 pompiers palois on
peut dire un grand merci à tous ces gens
là bas
et puis rappeler à tous ceux qui vont
attendre peut-être qu'à la montagne
c'est dangereux parce qu'on est là on
est juste là tout en haut de l'oignon la
voilà ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui c'est
une balade de deux heures trois heures
c'est la haute montagne encore qu'on
essaie en sécurité et puis la rive
désactivant comme ça si ça peut servir à
d'autres
là en fait il ya deux choses diagnostic
vital qui est engagée à très court terme
et puis si toutefois on arrive à faire
quelque chose du point de vue mécanique
le principal reste ce sera les séquelles
cérébrales quoi hésiter à voir des ne
pas reprendre une fonction
intellectuelle totale le bon vin
certifié parce que il peut être
lipotherm aussi pascal infos fiables
alors au bout et le pastel donovan
médecins avec lesquels s'entassent êtes
un ami de donc bon il est dans un état
très critique puisque suite à sa chute
il était en arrêt cardiaque et
respiratoire
je pense que c'est mieux voilà donc là
tout est en train de se jouer aux dés
son pelage de sallanches
voilà
voilà au revoir
partie des trucs pénible quoi c
à la limite c'est ça que plus
quel plus pénible c'est l'entourage 3
tant que tu es sur place tu es dans une
logique de gestuelle dans une logique de
technicité c'est là des choses à faire
et à paul temps à la limite de thé
mouvoir quoi après quand tu comment
savoir l'entourage les gens qui
s'inquiètent et pleure tu dois commencer
à rentrer dans des explications
e
tu perçois l'émotion quoi sur le pilate
été
t'as plus grand chose d'autre à faire
qu'à et émouvant là ça c'est dur à gérer
enfin six parties
il est resté longtemps inconsciente elle
un vitryat ce bilatérales moi je ne vois
pas bien non enfin peut-être que la
médecine fédé des prouesses et puis ils
vont peut-être le sortir de là enfin mon
avis il est mal barré c'est clair que
quand tu te bats pour pour pour essayer
de faire vivre quelqu'un tu as envie que
le résultat soit positif cwatupe ne
serait pas quoi et puis c'est sûr que
quand ils sont la limite de mourir ou de
vivre si nous on peut faire basculer du
bon côté c'est clair que c'est pour ça
qu'on fait ce boulot
ouais c'est surtout pour ça vous pourrez
plus faire d'autres secours sis en
psychologie comme on n'arrivait pas
faire le pas quoi donc mais on fait le
pas en plaisantant ils ont fait le pas
racontez-nous secours quand il se passe
mal
en fait on est quand même assez soudé et
même quand on boit le café le matin et
qu'on se rend compte de trois courts et
tout c'est notre manière d'évacuer le
truc qui nous restent un peu sur le
coeur et le fait d'en parler avec
d'autres souvent entre collègues souvent
ça passe quoi faut pas se poser on peut
pas se poser des questions tout le temps
pour tout le monde c'est notre autre
chose
[Musique]
les décisions malheureusement j'ai pas
les moyens techniques les performances
des moyens techniques dont on dispose
actuellement fermé du 20 février le père
et fils à sallanches et d'accès dix
minutes après l'arrivée à une succession
de dysfonctionnements majeurs et après
dire c'est la mine mal derrière celui
qui va se retrouver au tribunal
administratif ou ce que tu veux devant
la corde aux lyonnais et aux autres un
tiers monde il ya des dysfonctionnements
majeurs faut que ça s'arrête et c'est
pour ça qu'on a pris des décisions c'est
moi ou les médecins qui travaillent avec
commande de secondaire 2 grâce à leurs
dons clan près de l'hôpital chamonix et
sellette depuis plusieurs années et
actuellement il ya des démarches fort de
l'administration pour le fermer à ce
train d'évacuer sur chamonix re à
s'éloigner un peu plus du lieu de
travail qui est sale engeance à des
délais de vol ça l'air de rien de dire
ces dix minutes de vol dans un sens dix
minutes dans l'autre mais derrière c'est
une succession de décisions que l'on
doit prendre pour pallier tel ou tel
risque telle ou telle situation telle ou
telle urgence
est-ce qu'il faut privilégier la
sécurité secouristes l'urgence pour la
victime c'est des choix qui sont
soupçonnés pas être amené à réaliser
comme ça hors en 2020 c'est inconcevable
côté remémore lipotherm est mort
oh [__]
et ça les connaît mais qu'est ce qu'il a
vu comme billet pour aller y en ait la
paix par la sorte d'alcatraz
mais il a beau être il a peut-être pris
au bord la probante il a dû aller nager
on lui demandera
pour que jamais
il était sur la berge il est monté sur
un bout de glace ou en passant juste
faire un petit tour comme ça reste un an
voire de longs et puis en fait le vin
s'est levé et il s'est retrouvé à être
poussé au milieu du lac là aujourd'hui
un iceberg milieu des montagnes avec un
type dessus demain ça sera peut-être une
locomotive à l'envers des aiguilles non
il n'ya plus rien qui nous est un
voilier sur la mer de glace des pompiers
aux femmes de clients rocco siffredi aux
grandes montées à partir du moment où
c'est pas dramatique on peut toujours à
en rire
le massif les gens déambulent dans tous
les sens sur l'espace du tout parapente
tombe sur une ligne de haute tension et
1000 volts 60 mètres sol et le guen
était dans sa voile allez je me fait
rien il me prend en photo alors j'ai dit
ça va ça va t'elle moral il me dit non
pas du tout et je dis bon non plus parce
qu on est comme deux oiseaux sur un fil
électrique a été tous les deux et puis
ça s'est bien terminé et ça fait un
petit amitié entre nous deux ce
téléphone de tintin on n'est pas super
héros c'est pas parce qu'on a un
uniforme connaît dans un hélico qu'on
est les super héros j'ai pas besoin de
ça pour être super héros je bois mon
petit canon le sort et que je chante du
luis mariano je suis déjà un héros
auquel je vais chanter à la chorale à
l'église je suis un héros parce que je
suis championne taylor ben quoi c'est le
fait de vouloir être au service des
autres tout simplement
donc ce métier c'est vrai que c'est une
c'est une belle nouvelle terminaison
peut-être parce que j'avais envie de
faire dans ma vie
quelle météo 3 sur chamonix côtes et
cols du midi alors renoncer complètement
fauché on peut pas d'envoyer l'hélico
auront été bien au téléphérique de
l'aiguillé du midi se terminait en
général ces discours qui laisse le plus
de souvenirs
en plus il n'a pas grand chose mais bon
avec le mauvais temps bailly il peut pas
remonter par ses propres moyens donc
dans le remonte nous pas les débuts du
secours en montagne mais c'était tout à
pied un même quand il faisait beau donc
vrai qu'on y pense un peu quoi quand il
ya un objet h m
je pense que d'abord c'est quand même
assez amoureux de la montagne et puis je
pense que tu es quand même tu es quand
même attiré par la nation de deux
services de secours en fait c'est quand
même si tourner vers les autres et je
pense que les gens qui viennent là au
départ il ya le côté montagne il ya
quand même le côté secours qui est qui
et palpitant toujours rêvé de faire du
d'être guidé puis si par d'argent iv est
guide de faire du secours montagne ça
c'est c'est un rêve de gosse quand
j'étais à l'école quand on nous
demandait de traduire de résumer les
bouquins
c'était toujours pour premier de cordée
au c'était toujours ça quoi alors c'est
c'est vieux c'est vieux mais c'est
encore dans les tripes animaux ouais ça
arrive d'avoir peur ça m'est arrivé
plusieurs reprises je sois la foudre ça
me fait très peur je sois les chutes de
pierre et d'un jeu objectif en général
on ne maîtrise pas alors quand on
s'entraîne on essaye de maîtriser au
mieux on va dire c'est à dire de prévoir
ne pas se mettre dans des guêpiers par
contre quand on fait des lois du mot que
je puisse le lâcher ah merde pardon
excuses et quand on fait du secours on
est à la merci en fait de là où sont mis
les gens c'est pas nous qui nous sommes
mis dans le guêpier c'est eux et après
il faut essayer d'éviter les pièges au
maximum la peur je fais partie et fait
partie de notre job et ça nous fait être
plus rapide
peur ouais donc tout le monde est ma
france j'y crois je m'amuse
ouais ok go max 2 à malley
à l'afp l'un des meilleurs souvenirs
ce devait être en 90 on a sorti un gars
après 1h15 de sous une avalanche vivant
il était vg entre terre et quant à la
sortie ils voulaient voir le ciel on
voulait le coucher dans la perche il
n'arrivait pas on n'arrivait pas à
dénicher et il n'arrêtait pas de vouloir
se redresser et puis gueuler je vais
voir le ciel alors ça faisait rire tout
le monde on était moins 80 sur
l'avalanche et on va travailler pendant
une heure et quart qui ont été
récompensés par un vivant un m2 de tout
traumatisme par légère hypothermie
c'est la seule fois que j'ai vu ça pour
l'instant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
oh
merci michel durand maréval et un homme
cruel de manu tu prends son identité qui
vont encore nous récupérons même endroit
bah vous les mains pour cordiale on
vient de récupérer les troyens dems ont
l'air est électrique
on les a déposés auprès du couverte et
nous rentre à la dz à détroit passera ce
soir à la bad
terminée la difficulté parce que c'est
beaucoup ce cocon pratique des gens qui
connaissent rien montagne ils prennent
du retard se trouvait conditions
difficiles et réagissent mal quoi donc
ça va souvent envers dans l'accident
donc vaut mieux intervenir avant que que
du côté dramatique
et puis aller vers l'occident quoi
ces alpinistes qui étaient bloquées
techniquement parce que ils ont mis pas
mal de temps et puis les conditions sont
assez bonnes et donc leurs conclusions
c'était que les conditions ne leur
convenait pas et c'est donc je pense que
surtout ils n'étaient pas hésité pas
prêt physiquement et techniquement pour
affronter genre de course
on commence à avoir l'habitude parce
qu'on en fait quand même pas mal faire
un massage de personnes qui sont qui
sont pas particulièrement en difficulté
et puis qui ne se battent plus en
montagne quoi comme ça pourrait se faire
avant tu vas venir
ouais tu viens avec la facilité de
l'appel avec les portables et ben hilli
déresponsabilise vite fait quoi
maintenant le sac il faut les mettre
dans les sacs qui peut pas bien vu un
jour j'ai été maître mois et coûte
ouais alors écoute moi bien nous si on
est ici c'est pour vous secourir on
n'est pas là pour s'occuper de matériel
une fois que tout le monde est revenue
au calme parce qu'ils étaient excités et
ben on peut leur expliquer qu'ils se
renseignent sur les conditions de la
montagne que sur la course qu'ils
envisagent de faire et puis si c'est
d'envergure comme camp nou cette course
et ben on se prépare techniquement et
physiquement proxy lance pas comme ça un
peu facile après de nous appeler en
disant qu'on est bloqué alors que tout
va bien
[Musique]
la pauvreté des transports enfin merci
beaucoup c'est comme ça des transports
voilà donc ont été invités à votre santé
n'est pas prêt dépannage s'est passé va
on s'est lancé dans cette voie était
dégagée donné je dois la bombe
il commence à se faire tard les toutous
le versant soleil vous voyez bien que
c'était pourri toute façon on n'avait
pas pour réussir le winter pas descendre
dans cette voie là c'était ça ne va pas
ça pas assez long et puis il a fallu
qu'un un peu de neige pourris aussi il
enfin dit il savait sein de la façon
dont vous êtes monté ou redescendre et
de m c'est quand même mieux au mieux
vous auriez pu continuer quoi avait
l'air vue lassus comme c'était les
conditions n'étaient pas mauvaises
lorraine c'est quoi ces cinq six joueurs
dont une contre ce soit comme ça oui
maintenant c'est conserver rigueur c'est
fait maintenant on est les autres ce
sera une de son coin
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi les pioches que j'ai entendu à
la radio
apparemment ça dévissé dans le winter à
la verte
on va les voir on espère parce qu'à une
personne apparemment personne qui bouge
donc on va essayer de faire vite
y
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que je dire tu vois ça comme
un 200 mètres sous le sommet par manque
est dû rester accroché est qui et qui
bouge toujours didier il nous prend à
trois avec le médecin confrères enfin il
a une dépose au ouverte
[Applaudissements]
will et oga d'accord ok j'y vais publier
regarde je voulais mettre sur le pt au
dessus là y'avait que tu nickel tension
8 tensions tant sur lui
voilà c'est bon c'est bon
ça y est c'est parti les diplômes
vacance élevé partout le matin c'est pas
c'est pas trop bon coin des gens qui ont
qui sont tombés dans la les premières
heures d'ascension
donc c'est souvent souvent graves le
départ du matin en général dès qu'il ya
une mission à cames son engagement dont
on suit du début à la fin on attend que
les gens soient rentrés à la maison pour
se relâcher
j'attends que les mais les gens sont
engagées sur le terrain c'est un souci
ok mais vite on loue personnes étaient
bloquées dans la rigole central du
couloir et leurs quatre collègues en
bout de corde en contrebas et l'autre le
tout bloquer ok donc je vous remonte le
le gars allez c'est parti
ok
tant mieux quand même un bel et bien la
regarder les week-ends moi je vais bien
en bolivie pour cordialement pose de
pièges de l hôpital pour les identités
on voulait ce sont cinq à la base
terminée
[Applaudissements]
ah non c'est pas vrai
pas fou
pas bon du tout
sauf que là bas c'est une merveille de
guy de la compagnie
ces trois sujets
[Musique]
là c'est important d'aller tout vite
informé le président de la compagnie de
cet événement un
la famille du client ça va pas être
possible ces moments pénibles ça c'est
pas du tout pareil quand c'est des gens
qu'on connaît pas quoi lasser se
retrouveront de plein fouet à prendre en
pleine figure plein de choses qui nous
concerne nous aussi c'est un guide mais
ça peut être inscrit sur la en ce moment
on a plein de secouriste qui sortent en
montagne qui vont s'entraîner ça peut
nous arriver aussi donc c'est tout ça en
fait qui nous est renvoyée en pleine
figure ce type de situation c'est notre
propre vie notre propre mort
c'est ça en fait qui est le plus
difficile
[Musique]
ça fait aussi
donc il ya un traumatisme crânien sévère
et après il a un deuxième problème c'est
qu'il est en hypothermie
donc il était arrivé à 29 degrés et on
essaie de réchauffer mais il ya tout une
phase où il ya un refroidissement
initial on en connaît à 27 et 1028 c'est
un patient qui nécessite de la
neurochirurgie donc dès qu'il sera
stabilisée des températures on va dire
au motif 30 pour qu'on puisse le
transporter sans trop de risques on va
l'envoyer en hélicoptère à l'hôpital où
il est attendu c'est quand ça chauffait
whymper la silly un peux te dire que là
c'est non serait pas resté là on en
milieu d'après midi même fait maintenant
cinq chorales ont monté un là on a fait
au mieux quoi je pense bibi le but du
jeu c'est de dégager une victime le plus
rapidement possible les meilleures
conditions et puis de ramener tout le
monde entier a à la maison quoi
je viens de recevoir d'un que les
pousses de clients décédés ou une peur
c'est un couple qui a cinq enfants
l'aîné à 15 ans le dernier à un an
ça restera certainement un moment à un
moment fort quand c'est sûr et aussi
fort j'irai aussi fort voire voire
peut-être plus que le secours en
lui-même je pense que ça lui a fait du
bien nous non rencontrer pour qu'on lui
explique un peu ce qui s'était passé
les conditions du secours et ça a été un
la foire quand elle me parlait de son
mari je me rappelais un peu quand on
s'occupait de lui pour le pour le
redescendre pour l'évacuer c'est un
petit peu étrange un peu bizarre quoi
c'est tu as l'impression que tu l'a un
peu connus quoi ce gars là c'est assez
ouais moi je crois que je me voyais bien
au fond dans un coin au monde et des
funérailles pour mon enterrement jeu je
pense que
je pouvais quelque part y avoir ma place
moi
dans ce travail il faut pas jouer aux
costauds parce que on est des hommes
comme tous ces gros durs qui ramasserait
tous les jours des alpinistes morts dans
des courses sans aucune émotion je pense
existe pas ici c'est pas vrai non
[Musique]
moi j'étais en train de grimper donc
j'ai senti j'ai senti une traction sur
le bas là dessus je sais pas ce qui
s'est passé derrière mais mais je savais
qu'une chose c'était un endroit qu'il
fallait fallait pas tomber à cet endroit
là donc là les juifs du temps de penser
que j'avais eu une belle vie tels que
voilà j'étais loin
et puis n'a pas voulu comme ça sur une
miraculée mai mais grâce aussi à des
gens qu'on construit bien bien faire
leur boulot à tous les niveaux et ça
c'est vrai qu' on ne dira jamais assez
mais toute cette chaîne pour moi ça ça
fonctionne et tip top
lire les quinze premiers jours je
pleurais souvent parce que bon si tu es
comme ça c'est plus là quelqu'un qui m'a
dit monsieur via des choses vous savez
vous pouvez dépendre comme vous voulez y
fait c'est arrivé ce qui est arrivé mais
il ya une chose qui peut vous dire que
c'est ça c'est dehors ça se passe c'est
dehors ça se passe donc bah moi voilà si
j'ai décidé de vivre barral attentif aux
regard d'or en face qu'il faut pour
sortir
toi tu es une spirale qui monte toi ça
va mieux ça va mieux donc les gens qui
sont autour de toi ils sont ils sont
aussi mieux
et puis et puis les gens que tu cherches
qui était avec moi bombe à lui il s'en
sort pas ça veut dire place sa famille
qui est la belle que celle de la mère
serait qu' on a cartonné didace il ya
une règle de balle comme on et toulouse
ils prient pour ramener son client et
moi mais j'ai failli c'est pourtant pas
de ta faute
c'est ce qu'on dit mais bon mais c'est
pas c'est quand même pas satisfaisant
[Musique]
quand je me suis réveillé j'ai vu les
deux secouristes et le médecin je me
suis tout de suite sentie sauvé par des
personnes extraordinaires
l'alpiniste qui est décédée était mon
fils cela fait maintenant neuf mois que
je réfléchisse à saint-mont apprécié du
tout new en vous en faire part la
rapidité et l'efficacité du sauvetage
devisé plein l'an les d'alpinisme était
sa grande par dessus tout c'est l'écouté
et le soutien moral qui nous ont fait à
tous très chaud en fin de matinée une
petite dame nommée monique terminer
tranquillement une randonnée avec son
mari il descendait durant vos lits pour
rejoindre des chats va j'ai beaucoup de
chance de vous avoir et que vous soyez
au sa patte alité a voulu que ce bonheur
simple se transforme en accident stupide
avec tout ce que cela implique et ont
été victimes d'une avalanche le samedi
16 janvier 99
je ne trouve pas les mots pour vous
remercier de m'avoir sauvé la vie il ya
des choses qui ne s'oublient pas avec
toutes les reconnaissances alexandre
c'est beau non
surtout quand c'est une avalanche est
tout nouveau
on a toujours une pensée pour collègues
qui est parti à taureaux nés puis pour
pour les victimes du secours en montagne
ne leur devoir donc on aurait préféré
que la famille remercie aussi plutôt que
de les accompagner
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]